[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mike heller sports radio host the mike
heller show 1070 of the game
in madison wisconsin good to have you
back mike
things have changed a little bit here it
feels like in a week
last friday if i uh remember correctly
most people thought it's a real small
percentage aaron rodgers stays in green
bay
a week later what do you think that
feeling is now
yeah i think it's grown a little bit dan
i i think
um john [ __ ] former uh packers teammate
with aaron rodgers
does a show on the statewide network
that i'm affiliated with
um he thinks there's a better chance
james jones thinks there's a better
chance
i don't think those are coincidence uh
situations
these are former teammates that aaron
rodgers is still really good friends
with
so if they're bringing that to the table
this week that there's a better chance
of reconciliation
i think there's a better chance of
reconciliation did we learn anything
more from adam schefter's report
yesterday well it it uh
you know i i had a poll question a week
ago i sent to paulie uh
earlier this morning last thursday i ran
a poll who's the villain
in the packers bursa rogers situation
and it was dead even it was it was a
photo finish it was a half a percentage
point difference
i ran it again yesterday same wording
and rogers is the villain with 67
of the vote so it changed in the last
week
and then thanks to you i think it
changed a little bit i should put media
in the villain category 2 and maybe
they'd get a lion's share of the vote
well i was just wondering that that adam
held this
until draft day there wasn't any real
new
information in there even though he
cited leaked sources
and a team source but then said it's not
from the packers and not from aaron
rodgers
where do you think this information is
coming from and and where do you think
things stand now between both of these
parties
so i i i think it does come from rogers
and the packers and it's certainly
coming from
other emissaries uh who are those back
channel reports somebody connected to
the organization says
and somebody connected to the player
says i i agree
with your sentiment this morning i think
that there is a
much better chance right now than i
thought a week ago that aaron rodgers
is quarterback and one of the things i
was talking to you about on the show
monday
is that i think the best chance for both
in winning a super bowl is to reconcile
yeah
uh i agree with you if he goes to denver
i don't think denver becomes a super
bowl champion next year
i think the green bay packers can be and
what happens in 2022 or beyond
uh i know aaron wants some guarantees
that he's going to be in green bay but
the best chance for the green bay
packers to win a super bowl
and for aaron rodgers to win a super
bowl is to do it together
but i don't know how important winning
another super bowl is to aaron
like if you want the gm fired you're
telling free agents don't resign i'm not
going to be here
you want a salary that may make you the
highest paid player in the sport
those are things that don't help the
green bay packers
if the ultimate goal is to win a
championship
yeah i i think you know from the concept
of
if you get into the weeds of aaron
telling packers free agents i might not
be here i won't be here next year
that could be as simple or as um
as benign as just texting his buddies
hey
i might not be here next year in a
joking manner as
as opposed to saying sitting down with
them and before you do this
know that i'm probably not going to be
here i don't know aaron's hard to figure
out right he's a bit of an enigma
given his track record and some of the
things we don't know about him we just
know surface stuff
i sure wish he'd talk uh it doesn't do
any
we're not going to know anything until
after june 1st unless of course the
packers and aaron rodgers
sign a contract extension and dan i
think that's
far more possible today than i thought
at the beginning of the week
yeah the fact that there's been silence
here mike that
that usually you know i've been around a
long time
and it figures that you know they're not
kind of going at each other here or
you know and maybe something else comes
out and rogers
like there's a report that um rob
domovsky
says a high-ranking personnel executive
from an opposing team said the packers
could get two first-round picks and a
second rounder in a trade
so could get see that that's not fair to
this situation
i don't know and and i think if you add
in this story to that
any place aaron goes and they get two
first-rounders you know there's going to
be in the back half of the first round
below 20. how valuable are those picks
if you're getting number 22
next year and number 25 the year after
that i don't know that that's enough
value for what aaron rodgers brings to
the table
today so i still think and i and and to
me
the wild card in all of this is aaron's
uh
view of the green bay packers and a lot
of people want to attach
a motion to this i think it's less about
emotion and more
or about trust so if aaron doesn't feel
he can trust that the packers have dealt
with him fairly
then i don't think he's coming back if
he can set that aside
i think he'll be in green bay and i
think they'll be a super bowl contender
is jordan love going to be with this
team
in a year well i would hope so
i i would hope that they treat jordan
love in
a little bit of the same way that san
francisco treated
garoppolo until at some point that
reached its head
but but if jordan love can play dan
right if he can play in some exhibition
games
and show that there's something there
other than utah state
film from two years ago if he can show
there's something there
then a deal to send jordan love
somewhere else a year from now
18 months from now might bring back some
value but right now
two year ago tate from utah state is not
enough to give him any value
yeah there's no sample size here there's
no pre-season and
but i i get the feeling the packers know
what they have in jordan love
now they might want to see him with live
bullets there but he's not ready
the question is how long can he get
ready and how long would it take to get
ready because
this is really what you set up this
would have been ideal
except for rogers won the mvp if roger
threw 25 touchdown passes last year
then the packers are probably ready to
move on and then we would see jordan
love get this opportunity
right i've talked about that a lot over
the last couple of weeks for the last
couple of months dan that
that aaron went from 25 and 26
touchdowns in 18 and 19
pretty ordinary seasons below ordinary
by his standards
and then he threw a big wrench into the
mix by winning the mvp
otherwise you're right if he was pretty
good last year if he had thrown for 35
and got votes in the mvp and they still
make the nfc championship game
i don't know if this all comes to a head
right now but
um i think they were betting on jordan
love being ready in 2022
and rogers is essentially through his
performance last year and the
you know re reaching this loggerheads
that they're at right now it said listen
i i either need to be there for the
duration
or i'm not going to be there which one
is it great stuff mike as always have a
great weekend
and uh you know keep us honest if you
hear something
let paulie know thank you bud all right
thanks dan that's mike heller sports
radio host the mike heller show
1070 the game in madison wisconsin